speeches of the great Reagan
administration Peggy's a CBS News
contributor and the author of several
books a lot of bestsellers this new book
which I recommend to you for your
interest is some of her finest and most
memorable columns most powerful columns
from the last few years the time of our
lives
joining Peggy for this discussion is
John Dickerson John is the political
director for CBS News and the new anchor
newish anchor of Face the Nation that
show is getting more and more notoriety
because of the excellence of John I'm
sure you're watching it and you should
just last weekend he moderated Emma
Craddock debate popular press says that
he was the winner of that debate we're
looking forward to the conversation
whether you new to AER an old friend
please come back these conversations are
part of what we do and we couldn't do
couldn't do them without you so with
that please join me in welcoming Peggy
Noonan
John Dickerson thank you all right so
Peggy let's start with what did you
discover when you were going through the
process of putting this book together
what was the first thing that hits you
looking at all of that material I think
what I decided to do was pull together
30 years of commentaries columns up Edie
pieces essays the first thing that
struck me was that oh my god that
material really exists in boxes in the
backs of closets in attics and in a
warehouse out in Queens I got it all
together I went through it and a number
of things surprised me one was one was
how much you don't forget about what you
do we discussed this actually last
Sunday you are gonna find when you go
through all your work someday you're
gonna think you're gonna find a million
things that you don't remember you're
gonna think you're gonna have fabulous
moments where you look at something and
say my god that's lovely and I had no
memory of writing it that's not what
happens what happens is you
remember at all there was only two or
three things that I actually thought I
don't remember that when you first
started out why did you keep everything
I mean so I am the son of a pack rat so
I understand why I had all of mom's
things but why did you that first thing
you filed away that you ever wrote did
you think I'm gonna be famous someday
and I'm gonna want this or that's a
reasonable question I was really
surprised I'd kept everything I think I
knew for a very very long time that I
was a writer and I think I had it in my
mind that writers keep what they write
and so when I was a commentary writer at
CBS I would go home I was had a copy we
used to type on five ply news writing
paper the things that we did at CBS and
I must tell you it was very tender to
see these old scripts that were really
from typewriters and not even electric
typewriters I had a manual typewriter so
why did I keep it I just thought writers
keep their stuff I actually did think
that and when you went back to look
through those old scripts did you I mean
they feel different they smell different
yes they do that was there a moment
you're in the storage locker and was it
transporting I mean was there a little
time travel going on when you were
finding these old scripts
I remember Dan was do dan Rather was
yelling I need this immediately or some
other you know what amazed me the the
the CBS News which I worked in which you
work in I used to do daily commentaries
which were five minute shows which means
sort of a thousand word column a daily
column every day there was a column and
I also wrote hourly news broadcast so
every hour you know you had something it
the this year this year there you can't
wait for the muse do you know what I
mean the
sense that you have a deadline baby and
you are earning a union wage and you are
gonna get your $1,000 a week if you do
this work and there's and sometimes it
turns out well because you got it going
on sometimes it doesn't
the I don't know there was something
touchingly old about the typewritten
stuff there was something poignant about
it was there a trick when you were
writing like that at first did anybody
say to you here's how you when you can't
think of a darn thing and the five
sheets of paper and in the typewriter
are blank and you have ten minutes left
yes did anybody say here's the here is
the break glass thing to do to get
yourself to figure out how to have a
fast opinion in ten minutes
no I can remember as a writer the old
fellow's in the newsroom telling me look
if you don't know how to begin the piece
there's always hey Mabel listen to this
I I also found that if I if I couldn't
find the lead to a commentary but I made
believe I was talking to a friend about
the commentary I'd write dear Joel I'm
writing a piece about and then I'd start
going and then I would see what the lead
was because the lead was what I'd tell
my friend Jo so so yeah there was a bit
of that but I learned a lot of magic
from the guys in the newsroom the old
newsroom who that you used to visit as a
child which was the newsroom I worked in
in the 70s and 80s Murrow used that same
but instead of Mabel he used the Lord's
son which as a good practicing Catholic
we wouldn't say out loud but tell us
about the Mount st. Helens lesson you
learned oh that was a fabulous small
thing I was a young news writer at CBS
News I was putting together hourly radio
news broadcasts including the 8 a.m.
world news roundup which was a very
important CBS Radio Network show one
morning half my job was writing the show
the other half was sitting in a little
radio studio with
telephone and a tape recorder calling
people in the news and doing live
interviews with them then we would cut
that into little tapes called
actualities and they would be used in
the news broadcast
one day it's about a week after the
Mount st. Helens
a volcano blew big volcano huge story
I'm in the in the little CBS booth
calling around in those days there were
telephone operators and I knew the area
code for Mount st. Helens so I called I
got the the operator for the Mount st.
Helens area and then it was just so cute
I actually would say my name is Peggy
Noonan I worked for CBS News I'm trying
to cover Mount st. Helens she's got hi
Peggy how are you and and I'd say look I
I have to get fresh audio tape for my
bosses so they'll know what's happening
at at Mount st. Helens and I don't
really at this point know who to call up
and call on people for a week I need a
new name and they'd say things like oh
my cousin herb is a city councilman and
this in over from Mount st. Helens and
I'll connect you so it was a fabulous
world of telephone operators one day
this guy I get a guy on who's near Mount
st. Helens and I say what's happening
there and he says Oh everything's kind
of settled down I guess the big story
here is that the post office is closed
down we can't send letters anymore I
said why is that he said well because
after the the volcano blew all the lava
went up and then the dust came down and
then everybody went out with envelopes
put the dust in the envelopes and went
to send it to their friends as mementos
and I found that so hilarious the lava
came out in the machines in the post
office and broke the machines now that
was not grave and important enough
information for a great organization
like CBS News to use in one of its
broadcasts so I gave my editor some
other stuff to use but I mentioned to
this young guy this bright young kid in
the newsroom named Charles Osgood I
mentioned to Charles Osgood what the
funny
I had just told me about the post office
broke down and Charlie Osgood
immediately went that's the lead use
that get that audio tape and I was
surprised because I thought that's not
interesting to the public that's only
interesting to us it made us laugh and
he explained to me no no if it's
interesting to us it's interesting to
the public the public is like you they
will appreciate a story like that the
meaning of the ash falling out of the
envelopes and people gathering mementos
that means the crisis is over and people
are having fun again and sending
mementos of the disaster to their
friends so it's a story that interests
you something you might tell Mabel
you're developing your list of how to be
a young writer already yeah was when you
well let's go let's continue with the
process so you've been to the storage
locker you've got all of this out in
front of you how did you sort all of
this material what criteria did you use
I read everything I'd written now some
stuff words was just newscast that I put
aside who wants to read a newscast but
everything that was an essay or not bad
or something that argues for a point of
view I just read everything and I
literally made three piles the yes pile
for gee I love this the maybe pile for I
don't know I'm gonna have my friends
come in and read this and the no pile
you know the no pile was easy it's like
this isn't good enough we figured we'd
have 500 pages I got some boxes all over
the place you got to be discerning
eventually the yes pile was about this
high and then we had to make it the yes
yes I loved this file which had to be
about that I and that was just fun that
was just a pleasure that gave me a sense
John that that I had had a career and in
the career I had said interesting things
that that I meant as a contribution do
you not I mean I meant as a serious
thing and that's a fabulous feeling to
have yeah you know worth keeping yes
worth keeping and then worth putting in
a book I keep saying something horrible
on the book tour the horrible thing I
keep saying is and I can't stop saying
it is I'm a
to prove and I was teased about it by
Mickey
Mika Brzezinski the other day is that I
actually love this book and I just love
it so much that I can't not tell people
today I was up I actually got the worst
I was the worst I had my worst book to
her moment today I was up at the Capitol
and I met with Capitol staffers and I
was getting goofy because at a certain
point on a book tour you do get goofy
and I picked up the book and I said buy
this or you're gonna die and some of
them sort of wrote down by this don't
die so sorry I'm going off on no no I
was trying to figure out what the segue
was from that I have no idea buy this or
you will die is my message yeah so do
you have the yes yes pile and you know
we're talking about you wrote things
that you had some weight over time yeah
was there and I've asked you this before
but I'm gonna ask you for the benefit of
this audience was there a through line
through the years where you felt like
huh I've been mulling the same ideas
I've been interested in character of
public people character as it
demonstrates itself in private moments
totally totally
for one thing you know what look at your
work I think you will find this look at
your work see if you find it the me of
30 years ago sounds exactly like the me
of today I would have thought I would
have improved as a writer
no but I'm quite serious but the me of
30 years ago was the me of today which
gave me this feeling which is just a
thought I'm holding in my head maybe you
become yourself earlier than you know
you know but I was kind of thinking I'm
gonna go back and find touchingly
awkward youthful pieces to tell you the
truth I didn't it sounded just like me
it could have been written yesterday
that's one thing second thing is my
subject is America and full-stop a third
thing I am very and I could see this as
I went through the work I am very
interested in the subject of courage
shown courage
courage in the past courage that changed
history I'm interested in in the meaning
of the character I'm interested I and I
write most movingly
to my shock about the meaning of work
yeah the meaning of work in a human life
so you're Tennessee Williams piece I
love the line about and I'm trying to
think of a way to ask this so I don't
butcher it and let you tell it but about
the work he did after he stopped being
famous yes which is so touching to me
when Tennessee Williams died awkwardly
in a in an absurd accident in New York
City in a hotel accident too young I
think in his 60s you know it was a news
story Tennessee Williams had been a
great American playwright from The Glass
Menagerie through Cat on a Hot Tin Tin
Roof and a streetcar named desire but
what and I I like very much when people
who are important to me or important in
general died I I really try to capture
the meaning of their lives and/or their
work and so I was interested in
Tennessee Williams but what interested
me most about him in studying him and
interviewing people about him before I
wrote the piece about him what
interested me so much was that every day
he heroically got up and did his work he
sat at a typewriter and he wrote his
Tennessee Williams plays after his great
inspiration had left him after his
genius had abandoned him after the muse
had departed he still got up every day
and did his work and I just it kind of
choked me up to think about that he was
surrounded by a generation of writers
and actors directors and producers who
had in various ways as they used to say
in America sold out stopped trying to do
art stopped trying for greatness
and instead make commercials on TV about
wine do you know that and that's not
what he did got up every day and he
worked and I and so I just wanted to bow
to that right
the nobility of doing that even after it
was even when he knew it wasn't gonna
work right how many days can you go
without having it without writing what a
great thing to say does writing include
making notes on my thoughts and things I
hear and and well you know observation
so you know what it means if Charlie
Chaplin said I've got to go write or I
don't think I deserve dinner so that's
what I mean I mean you know I mean so
sometimes writing notes can feel like
you've written even if you even though
that piece that goes to the editor and
people go and see I would love to be the
kind of writer who has a lovely mole
notebook that she keeps in her pocket
with a lovely cross pen or whoever makes
great pens
instead I'm a frantic do you have a
piece of paper person do you have a
pencil I write notes I am carrying a big
on everything also on most disheartening
Leon yellow stick ups they're called
those yellow those two notes post-it
notes it's so humiliating if you saw my
desk its post-it notes all over the
place and then I can't read the
handwriting I do that all the time
because I'm very interested first of all
in the world and I'm very interested in
people I'm very interested in what's
happening and I'm very interested in
alright this is my thought I think this
is correct
check this out so am i doing that a lot
I'm doing that every day of my life
but do I enjoy sitting and writing a
column I do not well so two separate
things
I just don't know that's the that's not
the fun part the fun part is the notes
there's an apocryphal story about
somebody interviewing at Time magazine
at one point and going into the editor
and set editor and saying you know I
really love writing and the editor
didn't hire them because nobody who
writes loves writing you know somehow
that's the way to be although two people
know three people now I can think of who
were columnist and very fun columnist
really did claim to love it George Will
who has said to others that he on column
day he's so happy because he gets to
write a column on column day I have an
upset stomach but he's happy
because he gets try to call him Bill
Buckley loved to write his column and
Bill Sapphire once
oh well that's love to write a column so
there you go but I don't and I don't
understand people who love it although
it's very pleasurable as they say to
have written a call yeah it's so yeah
it's that's measurable so tureen your
work maybe I took so much pleasure in
going through the work because I
understand I never liked doing it but I
guess what I was getting at was the the
Tennessee Williams in you which is to
say the writing is what you do I mean
you you don't go on vacation to get away
from those notes those notes go when you
want absolutely but that's part of life
writers record what they record you
don't not like to tune I would not like
it to not do that yeah well I agree so
you you wrote also in this context
writers have to proceed through life
with an attitude of openness do you
think that's still true of the people
who write about politics these days oh
that's a great question it should be
true of people who write about politics
you should be I mean the the thing I
said there in the introduction is you
want life to wash over you and through
you you want to be responsive you want
to be observant you want to be right
here right now do you not I mean that's
what writers ought to do I suspect those
who if you mean writers on politics
those who go on the campaign trail and
watch politicians do their thing up
close day after day my goodness after a
while that would become rote stale
difficult as it does for the politicians
themselves it's that sort of what you
meant well I met also columnist too I
mean whether there's a you feel like I
mean whether that sense of openness you
still see it out there in the writing I
mean Buckley and SAFF there was an
openness to Buckley and Sapphire even
though they were they came from a point
of view and ideology and Buckley and
Sapphire were thinking a lot
I like the sound of thinking aloud I
love the sound of a columnist working
out his or her thoughts right in front
of you and you can follow the thoughts
and see where they wind up that to me is
is kind of interesting and fun D are you
referring in part to this think there's
a in the introduction to to the book
which if you don't buy you'll you'll
feel you never truly lived which is
which is a slight improvement from dying
in in the in the introduction to the
book I described the different kinds of
columnist that there are I mean there a
columnist who don't declare their views
on anything but of course you've
discerned their views on things there
are colonists who are conservatives with
no enemies to the right liberals with no
enemies to the left there's the pure
information columnist who asks you know
how will it all end we'll see there's
all different kinds of you know there's
all different kinds of ways to be a
columnist i think i i i try to keep
fresh in part by i write a lot about
politics which means necessarily i am
writing about what takes place in this
great city but I don't live here and I
don't have friendships and relationships
and enmities that I know of in this city
and it helps me sort of see more clearly
and be more responsive not to be
emotionally enmeshed and financially and
mesh do you mean there's a lot going on
that I'm very happy I'm apart from let's
talk from because I live in New York the
clean nice more that's really not what I
mean but but New York doesn't bother me
because I'm not in finances do you know
what I mean it's sort of I don't have to
be in mesh they're under way let's talk
about speech writing and we're gonna
have questions at the end here so if hmm
all the things that I've forgotten ask
about you can you can ask about so
speech writing we talked about this
before as well but one of the things I
love that you said
the Harvard talk that you gave was the I
was being able to intuit
what Reagan meant and felt without him
even being there somebody else who had
worked in a White House said that if
that you knew a good president because
you could think of the three things they
wanted when they weren't around and you
couldn't talk to them
but you knew because they were clear and
you could operate pretty much knowing
where you were gonna get to and then
finally you talked to the principal and
or the president and they would and they
would give you their specific view but
let's talk a little bit about that what
that was like with Ronald Reagan knowing
what he wanted and there's obviously a
specific case we'll talk about the
speech on the Challenger that you worked
on with him but just that that quality
of leadership Chris Matthews who had
been a speechwriter for Jimmy Carter
once said to me we met when I was a
speechwriter for Ronald Reagan and Chris
in his blunt and direct way said
immediately to me I'm so jealous and I
said what are you jealous of and he said
you know every day what your guy thinks
I never knew what my guy thought it was
very frank and that was how he felt on
that day but I understood what he meant
those of us who worked for Ronald Reagan
first of all we were philosophically we
were conservatives and so we had a sense
of conservative reality of the
conservative Canon of how conservatives
think we were conservatives second of
all we knew everything that Reagan had
read we if I knew him less than the
other speech writers but I had followed
him for many years and admired him I
could at least to some degree anticipate
his thoughts I could also anticipate how
he might put something I could also if I
came up with something that I thought
was brighter funny I'd have a sense of
whether or not he'd think it was bright
or funny do you not I mean and whether
or not that would work for him what was
easy about it was you would just do your
best throwing the ball best you could
and at the end of the day he was gonna
let you go forward and do it that way or
he was gonna say so sorry that doesn't
work I told the story
earlier today when he first this to me
speaks of the great sweetness of that
man
when I wrote my first speech for Ronald
Reagan it was a little Rose Garden
speech and it was announcing I was
brand-new in the White House I didn't
know how to do anything I'm brand new I
didn't know where my office was and they
give me they assigned me the Teacher of
the Year speech Ronald Reagan's gonna
announce who's the Teacher of the Year
in the Rose Garden so I was idiotic
enough to be excited oh my god I get to
write the Teacher of the Year speech so
I knew it should be short I knew it
should be two or three pages but I was
young and I was so eager to prove myself
and I was so on fire so I did write a
speech that said hello the teacher of
the year is is Miriam Smith from
Columbus Ohio and this is what she's
done and lent let us now talk about a
serious defense of the West and I did a
history of us frustrations with the
Soviet you know the defense of the West
Edmund Burke was right that so was
Whittaker Chambers so it was ten pages
long so I loved it I thought isn't this
exciting my boss took it went over it
and he kind of laughed but he didn't
change it and he sent it in and Ronald
Reagan went through the speech before
the Teacher of the Year ceremony and he
really nicely put in it just without a
ruler but a straight line through about
80% of the speech he connected the
adequate beginning with the rather sweet
fourth paragraph and then jumped to page
five
but then he wrote a note up on the top
that said dear Peggy welcome it's so
great to have you here how I would have
loved to have given this speech but
there just wasn't the time and it was
like do save this maybe next time yeah
but and I because I knew nothing and I
was new I thought he meant it I thought
I had done a great speech but
unfortunately we had just run out of
time that I gave it to my boss who read
Reagan's note and laugh
yes and not enough time in the history
of mankind yes did you find any of those
handwritten notes and when you went back
and we were looking through your things
no I only have copies of that believe it
or not in the Reagan era the president
wrote you a note it all had to go into
the official file you never got to keep
the real stuff I only had the
autographed pictures that's all I have
from him and in a letter after he was
president so tell the story of intuiting
and then we'll have questions in about
five minutes but that that intuiting
what he wanted on the day of the
Challenger disaster which it which is
it's amazing that the speech you worked
on with him this is in the book there is
a lecture that I gave it Roger Porter's
wonderful class class on on government
at Harvard University the class is
populated by young people who will
probably go into government
Roger Porter asked me tell them about a
day that you worked in government that
turned out to be a significant or
important day for you and I thought
immediately of the Challenger speech day
because I wanted to communicate one
thing to them we all have jobs we go
into work each day is the same things
can get boring pretty quickly but you
always got to remember some day you may
go in and the world will blow up the
world will seem to turn upside down and
that boring stupid day from what you
expected nothing will be a day when you
have to bring it turns out it'll be a
moment where you have to bring your best
self straight into the work you do and
everybody around you is gonna have to do
their best work at that unexpected
moment and you never know when that
moment will be so that's what I wanted
to tell him so to tell him that I told
them this story of the the Challenger
blowing up obviously a big shock
obviously a very painful moment in
America we'd never had it lost men and a
woman in flight before I did not have to
this thing happened it was really awful
the speechwriting office was exploding
because that night was supposed to be
the state
the Union address so everything's
changing everything's moving phone calls
are being made I just went to my boss
and I said Ben I'm gonna start writing a
speech for the president because you
know he's gonna have to speak on this
and he's gonna have to speak on it soon
because this is big he said yeah you're
right go ahead go do it so I start
working and I just started to channel
how would Reagan put this what would
Reagan feel as I'm starting to work on
it and starting to comb through the
thoughts that I thought Reagan would
have a woman from the National Security
Council we ran in said who's doing the
speech Ben sent her to my office she had
taken notes on everything Reagan had
said in the previous hour in the Oval
Office when he found out about what had
happened at cetera to some reporters who
were there so she gave me that and that
became the spine of the speech you know
I knew exactly what Reagan thought so I
put the speech together the the speech
there's a number of things to say one is
that when you do a speech for a
president at least in the past you you
could do good work but when it is
staffed out to 500 people who get to
comment on it
they can kill it they don't mean to kill
it they can ruin it they don't mean to
they're you know they're just doing
their thing and they're trying to make
their own contribution but they will
often do it in a clunkier bureaucratic
or crazy way all right the thing about
the Challenger speeches we had no time
there was no time for to staff it no
time at all and so it could not be bled
of meaning do you not I mean all right
quick anecdote the speech ended with a
quote from a poet young poet who had
died in World War two named John
Gillespie McGee jr. he had written a
book called high he had written a poem
called high flight it that poem ended
with the words and slipped the surly
bonds of Earth to touch the face of God
I think it was as I working on the
speech for Reagan as I was working on it
I kept seeing CNN over and over again
repeat the video of these poor
astronauts we had just lost the last
video picture of them was them waving
goodbye as they went from the NASA
holding place out to the capsule and you
know they were waving goodbye with these
big gloves you know from their astronaut
uniforms and and it was so touching and
so sad as I watched that over and over I
remembered this poem by John Gillespie
McGee jr. which I have learned in
seventh grade in the public schools in
Massapequa Long Island why did it enter
my head I don't know it just did
I wrote that as the end of the speech
and I knew I had to write two endings
because I absolutely know if Reagan
knows that that poem high flight and
cares about that poem he is so gonna end
that speech with those words but if
Reagan does not know that poem he will
not care about those words he will think
that is that's just not right and he'll
end it sooner so I did two endings we
put on the TV the president comes on to
speak in the afternoon he looked
stricken he looked dashed he looked
upset as indeed he was he got to the end
of the speech and he did quote the John
Gillespie McGee jr. poem the president
left that day he left the Oval Office
feeling that the the speech had not been
a success it had failed to do something
essential I think he didn't know exactly
what it was but it had failed I watched
him on TV I was sensitive to his
feelings I picked up his sense of
failure and I went home so doubly sad we
were all so sad about what had happened
and then I went home sadder still
because it's very painful in life when
there was a moment that asks for you two
to meet it and you do not however
something happened overnight reaction
came in people started saying things I
came into work the next day Tip O'Neill
had called he could he found a little
schmoo googy like me the Democratic
leader of the House of Representatives
found an obscure speechwriter to say you
did good work for your country yesterday
that's still so touching to me I'm not
sure it would happen in this world
George Shultz called the president
called he says the first thing he said
to me was how did you know I knew that
that poem and I said Oh mr. president I
didn't know you knew it but I I kind of
thought you might and he explained to me
how indeed he did because it was written
on a plaque outside his daughter Patty's
school and when he would take her to
school when she was in grade school when
she was a little girl he would sometimes
stop and and read the plaque I asked him
he was very honest with me about his
feeling of unsuccess at the end of that
speech that it didn't as Lincoln said
Scour
it didn't break the ground I asked him
so he was honest about that and I asked
him well mr. president how did you know
what changed your mind what but how did
you know that that at least it had
attempted to meet the moment and he told
me well the first thing he said was well
you know Frank Sinatra called
and Frank Sinatra didn't call after
every speech there were moments when you
forgot with Regan that he had come up in
show business and there were moments
when you remembered and what Frank
Sinatra was telling Ronald Reagan was
Ronnie it landed do you know I mean
there were a number of ways that that we
figured it out but anyway that was a
dramatic day it was a day when everybody
did their best that's all just everybody
did their best and took seriously what
should have been taken seriously we're
gonna open it up for questions because I
have about a dozen more and that's not
fair so just right here there is a mic
hi my name is Elaine Mittleman first
have to say you both are exceptionally
good-looking journalists
and I think it could be second cousins
or something you look anyway that wasn't
what I was gonna ask but I'm from
Indiana and I just I'm gonna get choked
up here but I just spent the afternoon
thinking about congressman Lee Hamilton
and who just got the Presidential Medal
of Freedom yes and so did William
rekkles house and Senator Richard Lugar
did two years ago and the president
campaign one headline of one candidate
was something like his advisers are
concerned that he doesn't know foreign
policy and they're really having trouble
teaching it to him and other candidates
seem to be just trying to position
themselves democrat or republican you
know to be against somebody else or
something and it just it was just so
striking to me the contrast between
congressman hamilton senator lugar and
what we're facing today i'm not sure
what to say about that i think you're
saying that they seem to have been more
serious and knowledgeable public
servants in the past than what you're
seeing right now okay that is what
you're saying i never know the answer to
things like that one answer is a weary
everything deteriorates oh my god what
is the third law of thermodynamics
sooner or later everything turns to
something unpleasant i take comfort in
this I worked for a great president and
yet there were people who said what the
hell're his qualifications he's a movie
star do you not I mean and yet he turned
out to be in my view in the view of many
Americans according to the polls the
last unambiguously successful two-term
president in the United States but there
were people who dismissed him as a
right-wing nut job
showbiz grade-b actor television host
no nothing whoo yeah it did have two
terms as governor of California but
beyond that was really nothing so I am
ever hopeful but surprising that good
things will come in surprising packages
let me be frank I don't think that a
panda date for president of the United
States should be taken all that
seriously if he needs to be taken aside
once a week by advisors who try to quote
get him smart in terms of foreign policy
you ought to be running in part because
you are smart in terms of foreign policy
you speak in such a constructive
respectful way and commentary relating
the news your observations of people to
whom or what do you attribute attribute
that classy approach
oh what a fabulous question yeah thank
you so much why it's just natural I'm a
little shy on TV if you mean TV I'm a
little shy on TV and so I never get so
comfortable I go like this with somebody
do you not I mean or really want to get
in fights beyond that we're talking
about serious things big grown-up things
we should act like grown-ups right we're
based in Washington in New York we're
talking about the politics of our great
nation young people are watching it we
shouldn't make it base and vulgar and
dumb and merely partisan do you not I
mean we should try to be grownups and
show each other the respect that we are
due you know sometimes when I've been on
a panel in the past I've only been doing
the sunday shows for about the past 10
years I never did them before that and I
I found out that the other people on the
panel were surprised because I would
listen to them respectfully and smile
and nod like tell me more and sometimes
I felt they were looking at me like why
are you smiling and being polite and I
think because I am polite so I don't
know what to say about that beyond
no a certain all of our children need to
see us acting like adults
that's all I don't think I did but in a
way I had a million mentors I mean a
million people at at CBS and people I
admired people I admired in the White
House who were dignified dignified yeah
and gave the other person maybe the
benefit of the doubt and tried not to
act like jerks gentlemen here I'm a big
fan of your writing but I'm curious on
the on the speech that president the
first President Bush gave when he gave
his acceptance speech in 1988 the whole
read my lip thing which of course you
know got to be commercial Todd can you
talk about the genesis of the speech and
also was it your idea to have him say
read my lips or was it his idea well
President George HW Bush in 1988 when he
decided to run for president decided he
was going he had to make it very clear
to the Republican base to a Republican
base that had been skeptical of him that
he was not going to back any new tax
increases and so in his announcement of
his his run for the presidency in 88 he
and he said there will he said something
very colorful although I can't remember
what it was but there was like there
will be no new taxes from my
administration . .
this was simply his program this was his
policy it was only part of his policy
but it really was part of his policy
when we got around to working on his
acceptance speech a very heavily vetted
very staffed speech in which a number of
things were changed I wrote it always
from the beginning with his no new taxes
pledge in it but I noticed along the way
that pledge was being taken out by
someone in the staffing process and I
would put it back in here was my thought
and I would put it in very seriously I
had two thoughts one is well I agree
with this and I think Bush should see it
but the other is this is Bush's decision
and nobody else's not some little mouse
running around and campaign headquarters
you know with one of these great new
writing machines the word processors
where you hit delete on a sentence buddy
that's not your decision that's George
HW Bush's decision
another thing however so this makes
three things is I thought and I'm trying
not to go too long but I felt very
strongly that if George HW Bush declared
from the beginning of his presidential
run that he was not going to raise taxes
said throughout the presidential run
that he was not going to raise taxes and
then after winning the GOP nomination
doesn't put it in the announcement in
the acceptance speech that will actually
be a scandal and that will make the
party start to go boom and so I thought
don't do that so I kept putting it back
in and eventually George HW Bush just
decided to do it it would have been
quite a story if he hadn't then became
quite a story that he did here comes the
mic
first my name is Barbara dello and I
want to say you're one of my writing
heroines so thank you for your good work
your wonderful work I love to write and
I have for many years mostly for myself
now I'm concerned about the speed
demanded by internet news and internet
politics and that it takes away from the
quality of writing and the ability to do
to thoroughly research on a story could
you comment on that yeah I understand
your concern the Internet is 24/7 365
it's popping every minute I believe the
people who write and edit at political
websites and also at very thoughtful
magazines and websites are under intense
pressure to keep moving product to keep
putting forward work that gets a lot of
clicks a lot of readers you know one of
the worst things that has happened with
the technological change that is that is
swept what we do is that in the old days
the New York Herald Tribune would come
out and you know they put walter
Lippmann the columnist in a nice place
on the editorial page but nobody really
knew how many people were reading him it
was just kind of agreed walter Lippmann
is an interesting guy a lot of people
are reading them now young walter
Lippmann their work is judged by the
number of clicks they get so that it's
known if they're running traffic it's
known if they're getting attention this
is terrible you never want to quantify
these things because sometimes you know
it's horrible to quantify what people
are reading because sometimes things
that are worthy and serious and
sometimes things that are unpopular and
and divisive and tough are very worthy
of attention and and you can prove that
they're not getting it and so you'll
you'll assign if you're an editor less
interesting things too less interesting
writers I said that badly but you know
what I mean right it's a less
interesting writer
now John it's good for John John gets a
lot of clicks and it's it's fabulous for
him but I but I think it's it's it's
tougher for some others anyway I hate
that it's all quantified here's the way
here's my concern in what you say I I
came up in the in one of the last stages
of very rigorous very rigorous
grammatical and usage days you better
have your grammar right you better have
your usage write that sentence better
hold do you know what I mean but the
editors were extremely highly illiterate
and got to take their leisurely time
over a piece that would be on the front
page of The Times tomorrow
I think standards have fallen a bit and
everyone is under so much an intense
time pressure to get the new piece up
get it splashed out there you know get
it get it done that it has that has led
to a certain deterioration in editing
which leads inevitably to a
deterioration among writers because
writers learn by being corrected as I
learned by being corrected sorry and all
the way in the back thing
yes my name is kami Burt i'm the de
pakistani spectator and my question is
about during iran-contra affair or gate
but what do you think about the role of
media they were giving the impression
that you know us is ruled by some kind
of thugs there was no sense for morality
whereas after that event i'm a muslim
but i used to go to all sale church
where john point extra he was the
national used to go his wife was a
pastor there and he was a very very
regular guy I mean very ordinary person
and very patriotic person but media gave
very very bad impression about these
people so what are your thought on that
thanks look I wrote a biography of
Ronald Reagan called when character was
king and I wound up doing two rather
searing chapters on a ram contra which
was the worst moment in the Reagan
administration's history it was a mess
and it was due in part to managerial
misfeasance so that's just what it is
did the press blow it up make it more
colorful make it more dramatic use it to
to be a cudgel to hit Ronald Reagan and
all those who were conservative in his
white house over the head with yeah but
did Ollie north and bud McFarlane helped
the press do that by baking cakes in the
shape of keys and by dealing in exotic
ways with exotic people of representing
other nations and making very poor
decisions and seemed to be seeming to be
unmanaged yeah so you know I mean it's
been said over the years I don't know
who first said it that with the
mainstream the general feeling among the
mainstream media is that Republicans and
conservatives are either stupid or evil
but there's no two choices beyond that
iran-contra was used by by the foes
Ragan and his white house to prove that
he wasn't stupid he was evil that's how
it was used and what the heck these
things happen we we've seen them all
the moral of the story is try not to
hand people a scandal that they can harm
you with that's all Peggy you came up
through CBS News to me it was the gold
standard when I was growing up me too
your hero is back then and then today
who do you read and watch you don't want
everyone to miss I read all columnist I
want to know what they're up to
and I'm also self-conscious about the
idea that you know all colonists are in
the idea and observation and argument
business and I would be very embarrassed
if there was a major columnist who the
same week had a column that I had whom
we both had a column in the same week
within a few days and he made a point
and I made the exact same point do you
not I mean now sometimes that's
inevitable because somebody makes a
point that is actually believed one
point you feel has to be made but I keep
up with everybody because I know you
know there's various professional
reasons to want to I also read all the
other columnist because like I identify
very seriously with their desperation
know what I mean to come up with a topic
to come up with something worthy of
their readers you know and and I respect
their lone cowboy us you know columnist
SAR kind of out there on their own now
especially woman columnist which I go
into in the introduction to the book
that that your life will be tragic
without reading who heroes I don't know
about heroes I so admired the great men
and women of CBS News when I was coming
up they were professionals some of them
at fought in World War two Korea I mean
they'd been there for the wars they
invented a forum called broadcast news
writing literally they had invented it
they were pros they were tough they
didn't know what to make of
young people like me this in the mid to
late 1970s a flood of baby boomers all
of us I know half of us were women which
already was surprising in the CBS
newsroom which was about 90% male and
middle-aged male where these young kids
were 27 years old were in tight jeans
fried boots
I had long blonde hair and aviator
glasses we all had aviator glasses and
we look like some invading Martian army
to these fabulous old men who'd covered
the Battle of the Bulge you know and
that they but they taught me fairly they
taught me well I can't say they were
heroes but boy didn't I think that the
world of them yes I will have to have
this one be the last question I think
we're out of time
Adam Higgins such a admirer of your work
wanted to ask about spirituality knowing
that the spirituality knowing that it's
important to you your your book on John
Paul the great was beautifully personal
you've written about the church about
Francis and it occurred to me with the
question that was asked about this sort
of graceful way that you approach things
just obviously this is a huge subject
but just the the role that your faith
has played in your life and in your work
and the way you approach I just think
it's all essential to me Sargent Shriver
was once asked describe yourself in
single words but in a in order of
importance and I read his list it was
like an look or Life magazine when I was
a kid and he he started with he said of
Sargent Shriver described Sargent
Shriver by saying Christian man husband
father patriot do you not I mean but he
started with Christian and and I was not
a very religious kid but I was struck by
that and I thought boy I bet people who
are religious really feel that way I
don't know I was I my way of writing
is to just let you have it let just tell
you what's going on in my head and my
heart my soul my psyche whatever the
word is my energy is going to my work
but all of that comes from a and
essentially Christian self by which I
mean nothing more than the fact that I
believe the Christian story I don't know
where to go to be on that but if it's
essential to you how boring and and
inauthentic
and somehow insincere for you to hide it
I just never felt I had to hide it so I
write about it or or you can see it
infusing my work in a way that I kind of
think you know some people really won't
like this but they'll put up with it and
some people won't like it so they'll say
it while a reader next week but not this
week and some people will like it and
think oh isn't that nice I feel that way
too
it doesn't matter it doesn't take
courage and it and it doesn't take
anything it's just being who you are
that's what I think well we're glad
you're who you are Peggy thank you John
ladies finding books now if you could
line up down the center aisle and then
head to the left we will get started as
quickly as possible
you